THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING ME
TONIGHT.
>>> THE 4TH OF JULY IS THREE
DAYS AWAY.
ACCORDING TO A BRAND-NEW FOX
NEWS POLL, PRIDE IN AMERICA IS
PLUMMETING UNDER JOE BIDEN.
I WONDER WHY?
39% OF VOTERS ARE PROUD OF THE
COUNTRY INCLUDING 46% OF
DEMOCRATS.
JOINING US NOW WITH THE REACTION
IS THE FIRST GREEN BERET TO BE
ELECTED TO CONGRESS,
REPRESENTATIVE MICHAEL WALSH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
PEOPLE CAN LOOK AT A POLE LIKE
THAT AND THINK THAT WE DON'T
LIKE THE COUNTRY.
IT'S NOT THAT.
WE LOVE THE COUNTRY.
WE DON'T LIKE WHAT IS HAPPENING
TO IT AND HOW WE ARE BEING
REPRESENTED.
IS THAT YOUR TAKE ON THIS?
>> TAMMY, I THINK THAT'S PART OF
IT.
I THINK THERE IS SOMETHING MORE
FUNDAMENTAL.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE POLLING DADO
YOU SEE A STEADY DECLINE OVER
THE LAST DECADE PLUS.
I POINT TO OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM
AND COVID EXPOSED TO US THE
GARBAGE BEING TAUGHT IN OUR
SCHOOLS.
THIS IS A FUNDAMENTALLY BAD
COUNTRY THAT AT ITS CORE IT IS
MISOGYNIST, RACIST, COLONIALIST.
IT WASN'T FOUNDED TO ESTABLISH
INDIVIDUAL FREEDOM FOR WE THE
PEOPLE AWAY FROM MONARCHIES AND
EMPERORS.
THAT IT WAS ESTABLISHED TO
PROTECT SLAVERY.
WHEN THAT IS BEING TAUGHT IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND ON TOP OF THAT YOU
HAVE THINGS IN MATH CLASS WHICH
WE DISCOVERED IN FLORIDA.
WORD PROBLEMS THAT TALK ABOUT
COUNTING THE NUMBERS OF
OPPRESSORS AND OPPRESSED.
NOW IN OUR MILITARY, THEY ARE
SAYING ON ONE HAND YOU NEED TO
BE WILLING TO DIE FOR OUR
CONSTITUTION AND FLAG, BUT IT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY IN ITS CORE BAD
AND FLAWED.
I THINK YOU TAKE ALL OF THAT
TOGETHER AND WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
A MILITARY LIKE THIS PRESIDENT
HAS AND THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE
HAS, IT IS OVERRUN WITH WHITE
SUPREMACY.
IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME YOU ARE
SEEING THIS TYPE OF DECLINE IN
PRIDE IN OUR INSTITUTIONS AND
PRIDE IN OUR FLAG.
>> I THINK THERE'S A COMBINATION
OF THINGS GOING ON.
WE HAVE YOUNG PEOPLE ESPECIALLY
BEING INDOCTRINATED WITH
LOATHING THE COUNTRY.
THEY DON'T KNOW BECAUSE HISTORY
IS NOT TAUGHT ANYMORE.
THERE'S NOT MUCH OF A
BACKGROUND.
WE DO KNOW A GOOD MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS KNOW THAT WHAT YOU
DESCRIBE IS A RESULT.
THIS IS NOT A NATURAL ORGANIC
THING GOING ON.
THIS IS A GROUP OF PEOPLE
RUNNING THE COUNTRY THAT HAVE
DONE THIS TO US.
ON THIS FOURTH OF JULY, THERE IS
A SENSE THAT THE 4TH OF JULY
MIGHT BECOME A PARTISAN HOLIDAY.
DO YOU ENVISION THAT HAPPENING?
>> I PRAY NOT.
I WILL DO EVERYTHING I CAN TO
FIGHT AND REMIND PEOPLE THAT
THIS FLAG STANDS FOR INDIVIDUAL
LIBERTY, THE RIGHT TO ASSEMBLE,
THE RIGHT TO FREE SPEECH AND THE
RIGHT TO CRITICIZE YOUR OWN
GOVERNMENT.
THERE ARE LITERALLY MORE PEOPLE
OUT RIGHT NOW, MORE MILITARY
MEMBERS OUT NOW WILLING TO DIE
FOR THE FLAG THEN THE ENTIRE
CANADIAN AUSTRALIAN ARMIES
COMBINED.
YOU KNOW WHO DOES APPRECIATE
THIS COUNTRY AND IS LITERALLY
DYING TO GET HERE?
THOSE OUR IMMIGRANTS LIKE THE
AFGHANS THAT WERE SO DESPERATE
TO COME TO THIS GREAT NATION
THEY WERE WILLING TO CLING TO
THE SIDE OF A JET OR PEOPLE
DYING COMING ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
TO YOUR POINT, IT'S ALL
SELF-INFLICTED WOUNDS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHERE WE WERE
IN THE MONTH BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
HIT WITH RECORD UNEMPLOYMENT
ACROSS EVERY SECTOR, BLACK,
WHITE AND BROWN, WOMEN AND MEN
WITH A ROARING ECONOMY, TAX
REFORM.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHERE WE WERE
UNDER THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION AND PEOPLE LOOKED
AT THE RESULTS IN THEIR LIVES,
THEY WERE PRETTY EXCITED.
NOW THEY LOOK AT EVERYDAY
PROBLEMS.
>> THIS IS IT.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT THE
DEBACLE OF AFGHANISTAN IS WHAT
SHOOK THE NATION TO ITS CORE,
REALLY.
WHEN WE UNDERSTOOD THAT THERE IS
SOMETHING WRONG THAT HAPPENED
AND WE ARE SEEING THAT KIND OF
FAILURE MOVE THROUGH EVERY
SINGLE OTHER ISSUE THAT WE FACE
IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT WAS NOT AN ACCIDENT.
THAT WAS NOT A BUG.
IT WAS A FEATURE OF WHAT WE WERE
TO EXPECT.